um thank you from the very bottom of my  heart for all that you've done  um for really being a hero that we  really need in a time like this  thank you so much darren i think there's  something wrong with your microphone  the time has come for you to come home  be reunited  the black panther has been a protector  of wakanda for generations  a mantle passed from warrior to warrior  in my culture dead  it's not the end  it's more of a stepping off point  you reach out with both hands and bust  and sekhmet  they lead you into the green wild path i  have breathed each other  get around forever  my son's childhood has been defined by  barack obama and now black panther so  thank you  hey that's way too much praise  you are gorgeous gorgeous  [Music]  in my culture dead  it's not the end